die nachrichten des tages heute mit
schwere waffen an die ukraine auch die
zum wiederholten mal wird saharastaub
einwohner von max hätten lieber einen
ergebnisse von heute nachmittag dortmund
kommen wollen
auf die ukraine ein rückzug aller
aktuellen debatte über die ostermärsche
cdu erneuert heute diese forderung sie
jahre ist es her dass prinz harry das
linksaußen politiker in der stichwahl
krieg getötet wurden niemand weiß es
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
gewinnt also 6 zu 1 gegen überforderte
weit nach norden transportiert sie sehen
russischen truppen die teilnehmer des
und die haltung der friedensbewegung zum
gesehen nun müssen sie sich neu
genau von rund 13.000 opfern unter den
britische königshaus verließ jetzt
nennt das geld aus der ertüchtigung
wolfsburger augsburg hertha bsc 0 zu 1
willkommen an diesem ostersamstag und
wir hoffen sie können es nicht einen
ostermarsches stuttgart wollen ihre
dass hier schon an der luft trübung über
ukraine krieg finden sie auf seite
entscheiden
initiative augenwischerei der schnellste
zeigte sich erstmals wieder gemeinsam
ich wähle lippen punkt fragen sie nicht
volle solidarität mit der ukraine zeigen
ukrainischen soldaten spricht präsident
dem mittelmeer der sahara staub hat
die zahl ist auch wieder dabei für den
erfreute und in der zdf- heute- app ein
mit seiner frau megan öffentlich in
wichtiger sieg für magaths berliner im
regelrechten run gibt es seit gestern
sport sehr gerne schönen guten abend und
selensky bis zu 3000 tote 10.000
bereits das südliche italien erreicht
weg wäre wenn deutschland heute waffen
laut veranstalter sind 2500 menschen
abstiegskampf keine tore im spiel mainz
europa und zwar in den niederlanden zum
das sind einige der themen von heute
auf diese briefmarke sie zeigt einen
warum alle anderen sind korrupt
bei uns wurden die wolken der
lieferte anstatt der ukraine geld zu
gekommen gerade jetzt wo in europa krieg
soldaten zum teil schwer verletzt
gegenrichtung süden getrieben hier an
zeichen des friedens wollte auch papst
gegen vfb stuttgart freiburg gewinnt
auftakt der von ihnen gegründeten
ukrainischen soldaten der dem russischen
warum ich makro welle um nicht zu wählen
lob aber auch kritik an zusätzliche
geben damit sie kauft in deutschland ein
zielinski verlangt neue sanktionen
herrsche sei es umso wichtiger zu
die alpen am frühen morgen erkennen sie
invictus games ein paralympischer
franziskus setzten gestern abend bei der
gegen bochum drei zu null das rheinische
kriegsschiff moskwa ein eindeutiges
waffen exportgeschäft beantragen muss
demonstrieren erklären viele von ihnen
militärhilfe für die ukraine für manche
und um die rechten zu verhindern
noch ein schmales wolkenband hier über
derby gladbach gegen köln ausführlich im
traditionellen kreuzweg andacht in rom
das nächste paket muss ein importverbot
das genehmigt werden muss die wahrheit
wettbewerb für kriegsversehrte auch
zeichen gibt seit dem untergang ein
doch die bewegung steckt in einem
frankreich vor allen dingen an dem
ein guter erster schritt die union will
ich bin ratlos wahrscheinlich gebe ich
aktuellen sportstudio
an der dreizehnter station im kolosseum
ist doch bundeskanzler scholz will es
dilemma umfasst die solidarität auf
schatten den dieses wolkenband brav über
veteranen aus der ukraine sind dabei
von russischem öl enthalten
kultobjekt irina hat heute morgen die
in der tabelle hat dortmund den abstand
nicht und es ist ein weiterer versuch es
weiter die lieferung schwerer waffen
einen leeren wahlzettel ab oder ich
eine klinik hat mir sie sind eine
waffenlieferung gar eine abkehr vom
die demokratische welt muss einsehen
übernahmen zwei frauen gemeinsam das
letzten marken bekommen
hinter münchen zumindest bis morgen auf
enthalte mich nicht umsonst hat emanuel
tag gab es dann viel sonnenschein von
zu verhindern kritik von vielen seiten
pazifismus nein sagen viele die waffen
holzkreuz eine ukrainerin und eine
und die schicke briefe mit dieser marke
der ostseeküste bis zum oberrhein und
herzensangelegenheit des britischen
sechs punkte reduziert leverkusen und
private über ostermärsche zehntausende
dass geld für russische energie
nur vier monate nach amtsantritt steht
makro heute hier einen großen auftritt
prinzen harry die in victor's games
auch jetzt in der nacht bleibt es meist
eigentlich geld für die zerstörung der
russin irina und albina befreundete
leipzig sind ebenfalls morgen gefördert
an meine freunde in polen georgien und
die jetzt geliefert werden verlängern
demonstrieren für frieden die
klar und nur im nordosten sind einige
kanzler scholz bereits unter druck
übersetzt die spiele der unbesiegbaren
mainz von zehn auf neun
demokratie ist
den krieg verlängern das leid wo sind
deutschland sie so stark die ukraine
pazifistische botschaft stößt aber auch
parteifreunde stellen sich demonstrativ
wolkenfelder unterwegs ist wird kalt die
die rechtsextremen wollen die deutsch
krankenschwester
zusammen mit seiner frau megan ist er
scharfe kritik gab es dafür vor allem
das russische verteidigungsministerium
hinter ihn das
unterstützen
spannend der kampf um den klassenerhalt
diejenigen die jetzt verhandeln gehen
temperaturen sinken auf plus 4 bis minus
auf ablehnung und
französische freundschaft beenden und
nach den haag gekommen um den wettbewerb
so sind trotz der neuen luftschläge auf
aus der ukraine
keine waffenlieferungen keine aufrüstung
härter hat sich durch den sieg auf den
meldet heute auch angriffe auf mikko
4 grad fast überall wird es also noch
trauer um joachim streich der
eine militär allianz mit russland ihr
das sei eine verfrühte versöhnungsgeste
für kriegsverletzte am abend zu eröffnen
15 rang verbessert stuttgart wird auf
live im süden auf lager für raketen und
dessert besonnenheit
kreisstraßen und den parks wieder mehr
müsst sie am 24 april besiegen marine le
gar nichts in dieser richtung frieden
mal kalt genug für bodenfrost dieses
rekordtorschütze des ddr fußballs ist im
gestern schon hatten sich die royals als
dem relegationsplatz wieder auf dem
pflegt und weniger die
artillerie am rand der region donetsk
menschen zu sehen die russischen
zeichen der solidarität mit der
west-ost-gefälle bei den temperaturen
doch einig sind sie sich nicht mit blick
alter von 71 jahren gestorben
da sinken die infektionszahlen weiter
gibt es auch morgen über tag im westen
angriffe hatten seit ende märz
relegationsplatz abgeschlagen kräuter
pen gibt sich siegessicher die verbalen
perfekte in den vordergrund stellt an
und lohans sammeln sich seit tagen
ukrainischen mannschaft getroffen viele
eigentlich abgenommen doch jetzt heulen
auf butter und andere gräueltaten
führt
allerdings werden wegen der feiertage
steigen die werte auf 15 bis 20 grad im
angriffe gegen sie seien ein gutes
russische einheiten die ukrainischen
scheint etwas ins wanken zu geraten alte
der sportler kommen direkt aus dem krieg
jede menge fußball am abend dann im
den anderen meer gelegen sein mag wer
seit tagen wächst der druck auf die
weniger daten übermittelt das meldet 37
die sirenen wieder in der hauptstadt
zeichen
osten sind es nur 10 bis 15 grad und es
behörden rechnen damit dass sie in
sowie der bogenschütze wolodimir musik
das bestätigt dass ich die wahl gewinnen
überzeugungen werden mitunter in frage
jeden tag bürgermeister klitschko
aktuellen sportstudio ab 23 uhr gast bei
bundesregierung auch schwere waffen in
ist da sehr zurückhaltend und besonnen
beiden gebieten gleichzeitig losschlagen
wird ein sehr sonniger ostersonntag
gestellt bin selber mit einem ganz ganz
der nach einer minenexplosion unter
kann die brutalität gegen mich steigt
führungsschwäche im kanzleramt schwere
die ukraine zu liefern fdp und grüne
forderte inzwischen die menschen auf
sven voss ist bochums torwart manuel
1568 neuinfektionen innerhalb eines
werden schon bald mitte der woche wenn
höchstens im osten gibt es ein paar
einem schädeltrauma leidet
genauso stark wie meine chancen in
großen zwiespalt heute hier weil ich
nicht wieder nach kiew zurück zu kehren
quellwolken bei einem leichten bis
sind dafür der bundeskanzler hält sich
waffen für die ukraine beide debatten
riemann
diesem rennen zu siegen
tages das sind
der regen aufhört
und man sicheren orten zu bleiben doch
wir kommen von der front und ich bin
mäßigen wind aus unterschiedlichen
durchaus sehr dass man die
der ehemalige weltklassestürmer und
in dieser frage bedeckt und bildet erst
gehen in die nächste runde ende vorerst
113.000 107 weniger als vor einer woche
richtungen wenn ihnen morgen was in der
aus der region um hier hatten sich die
völkerrechtswidrige und auch
mental immer noch bei meinen kameraden
rekordtorjäger joachim streich ist im
mal einen weiteren milliarden topf für
nicht in sicht
menschenverachtende gewalt in der
immer mehr verkommen zurück in ihre
nase kribbelt dann könnte das der
frankreich gegen frankreich titelt an
die jetzt weiterkämpfen nach den
russischen truppen zurückgezogen doch
ukraine stoppen muss auch mit waffen ich
29 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
alter von 71 jahren nach schwerer
die rüstungs hilfe ein großteil soll der
der krieg könne verkürzt werden wenn die
birkenpollen sein denn die birkenpollen
stadt trotz der gefahr sie wollen sich
magazin so tief gespalten war das land
jetzt nimmt moskau die hauptstadtregion
wettbewerben gehe ich sofort zurück um
krankheit verstorben streich galt als
bin an sich auch gegen waffen nur ich
konzentration ist morgen in deutschland
ukraine zu gute kommen doch nicht nur
von putin nicht ihr leben diktieren
hinzu die sieben tage incident singt
ukraine rasch alle gewünschten waffen
wieder verstärkt ins visier mit
glaube dass man der situation
wohl noch nie jüngste umfragen sehen
unser land zu verteidigen
ikone des ddr fußballs und erzielte 229
extrem am ostermontag ändert sich an
lassen
die union sagt das brauche mehr nicole
entsprechend reagieren sollte und die
luftangriffen wie die menschen dort
geliefert bekommen davon ist ihr
makro zwar knapp vorn doch viele
erstmals seit ende januar unter 1000 und
mehr als
die ukrainischen bogenschützen müssen
situation gibt es glaube ich gerade
diesem wetter wenige dienstag und
präsident überzeugt weiterhin fordern
diekmann viel wurde in den vergangenen
damit umgehen zeigt aus kiew dominik
franzosen sind noch unentschieden und
treffer für magdeburg und hansa rostock
350.000 geflüchtete aus der ukraine sind
nicht her dass man weiterhin einfach nur
mittwoch könnte es im süden für etwas
liegt jetzt bei 8
ohne ihren trainer in den wettkampf
sie könnten das zünglein an der waage
tagen über ihn geredet über den
nett redet die friedensbewegung muss
löschmeister
die ukrainischen behörden im osten des
joachim streich zum hundertsten von
regenreichen frohe ostern
inzwischen in deutschland registriert
gehen die mikros sie druck fiel anfang
176,5
wieder raketeneinschläge in kiew das
sein
landes die bevölkerung zur evakuierung
schützenpanzer marder schweres gerät an
antworten suchen sagen experten denn in
doch auch aus russland suchen menschen
insgesamt 102 länderspielen geehrt im
lob an makro haut ab skandieren sie
ein referendum über europa so nennt
april im krieg gegen russland eine
auf solange das noch möglich sei also
ziel laut russische militär eine
der aktuellen lage habe der pazifismus
die ukraine ja oder nein die
hier schutz bürgerrechtler kritische
londoner wembley stadion ein
heute in paris und anderswo zehntausende
weitere sportlerin ist aus mario pohl
strafraumspieler par exellence
wenig zu bieten vielmehr wirkte er
panzerfabrik die ukraine sprechen von
vor der erwarteten russischen offensive
bundesregierung hat sich stattdessen für
journalisten oder kulturschaffende auch
frankreichs präsident makro die
vermutlich nach russland verschleppt
erfolgreich gegen das dfb team bei
demonstrieren gegen rechts aber auch der
zynisch das potenzial wäre jedoch der
eine erhöhung der ertüchtigung
entscheidende zweite runde der
einem toten und mehreren verletzten die
doch auch andere teile der ukraine
worden es sind diese geschichten die die
ihnen sollen langwierige asylverfahren
olympia 72 in münchen artistisch zwei
amtierende präsident kommt nicht gut weg
initiative entschieden ein wortungetüm
präsidentenwahl morgen in einer woche in
bewegung hat eine riesige strahlkraft
wurden wieder angegriffen volker tucek
anspannung steigt in der stadt auch bei
ukrainische mannschaft von hier aus der
wir sind gegen die verharmlosung der
erspart werden das kündigte
hinter dem rund eine milliarde euro für
werden sie denn viele leute auf die
hat mir
jahre später bei der wm
der ersten runde kam der amtsinhaber auf
welt erzählen will und gleichzeitig
danny a sie ist deutsche übersetzerin
justizminister buschmann in der welt am
rechtsextremen und auch dagegen dass wir
straße bringt momentan ist es allerdings
55 länderspiel tore sprechen für sich
die ukraine steckt die ersten kritiker
mitten am tag mitten im wohngebiet
knapp 28 prozent seine konkurrentin die
versuchen die athleten auch ein signal
zusammen mit ihrem mann ist sie gerade
sonntag an ziel sei es dass sie schnell
zwischen einem rechtsliberalen und einer
so dass es gar nicht so eine starke
besänftigt das bedeutet die ukraine kann
ein spieler mit seltenen gaben man muss
schlagen die artilleriegeschosse ein und
der zuversicht zu senden
erst nach kiew zurückgekehrt aus dem
rechtspopulistin marine le pen auf gut
rechtsextremen wählen müssen
botschaft gibt die verstanden werden
eine arbeitserlaubnis erhalten
dann aussuchen was sie glaubt an waffen
ganz einfach auch ein bisserl den
westen der ukraine ein auf es ist nach
23 die stichwahl könnte richtig eng
große gefühle verbinden mich mit diesen
treffen war wo sich spaziergänger
frankreich 8 tage vor der stichwahl egal
könnte vielen ist die problematik
instinkt haben wie man vom tor braucht
wirtschaftsminister habeck von den
material was sie braucht wir stellen
fahrradfahrer
sicher ist weiß man nicht weil die
man muss natürlich taktisch und
spielen der sport gab mir wieder kraft
bewusst man müsste die themen
gestern in kharkiv der zweitgrößten
wer gewinnt es wird schwer die
grünen fordert von den teilnehmern der
werden deswegen müssen beide jetzt noch
mittel zur verfügung um das
technisch gut ausgebildet seien und dann
gerichte kommen das durch den winter
diskutieren doch heute beim ostermarsch
gegensätze zu überbrücken mehr als zwei
zu leben vorher saß ich am computer und
stimmen aus allen politischen lagern
gegebenenfalls auf dem markt einzukaufen
stadt des landes unweit der russischen
ostermärsche eine klare botschaft an
ja einfach nicht so viel überlegen als
ist erstmal eines wichtiger auf die
wenn wir es nicht selber liefern können
gewinnen mehr von christel hass viele
grenze
habe das haus nicht verlassen
russland es sei eindeutig wen
straße zu gehen gegen den krieg mehr zur
diese familie hat glück gehabt aber der
ich habe mich total abgekapselt
spieler in rostock und magdeburger
also das ist der richtige schritt strack
deutschland unterstützen müsse auch mit
erfolgreich als trainer danach weniger
schock welt vor allem carolina und wird
zimmermann war diese woche überraschend
veteranen aus 20 ländern messen sich in
sportartikel vertreter wurde er
waffen pazifismus sei aktuell ein ferner
in die ukraine gereist unter anderem mit
es wohl noch lange tun
schließlich kurz nach seinem 71
es fühlte sich ganz nah an das geschoss
den nächsten tagen in verschiedenen
anton hofreiter von den grünen beide
disziplinen und werden den krieg in der
traum sagt habeck der erste deutsche
geburtstag erlag joachim streich einem
flog vorbei ist knallte eine frau warf
übten scharfe kritik am kanzler
krebsleiden
ukraine
hofreiter bleibt bei seiner haltung
ostermarsch liegt lange zurück am 15
sich auf mich um mich zu schützen
der neue traumata und verletzte
alexander zverev ist im halbfinale des
hervorbringt nicht aus ihren köpfen
das ist ein erster schritt aber es ist
april
atp tennis turniers von monte carlo
1960 gingen atomwaffengegner auf die
ihre mutter versucht sie zu trösten
verdrängen können
natürlich kein ersatz für die direkte
ausgeschieden gegen den an nummer drei
lieferung schwerer waffen und es ist
straße der beginn einer neuen bewegung
weine nicht meine kleine es ist vorbei
gesetzten stefanos city pass hatte zwölf
auch kein ersatz dafür putin vom
mit fußball und tennis saison endspurt
alles vorbei wie viele zivilisten in dem
zeitweise mit hunderttausenden
schon den ersten satz mit 4 6 ab gegeben
geldzufluss abzuschneiden das heißt
in der fußball bundesliga am 30 spieltag
demonstranten
energie embargo insbesondere öl embargo
heute waren bundesweit 80
im zweiten wurde die überlegenheit von
zeigt sich borussia dortmund in torlaune
muss weiter auf der tagesordnung bleiben
cc passen noch deutlicher der grieche
veranstaltungen geplant jan frederik
und feiert verfasst 80.000 zuschauern
gewann mit 6 2 und trifft morgen im
fischer schluss mit russlands angriff
einen beeindruckenden sieg die vier
finale auf den spanier alejandro
davidovitch china
und deutschlands tennis frauen haben die
finanz beim billie jean king cup in
kasachstan klar verpasst und spielen nun
gegen den abstieg
angelique kerber verlor durch das 6 4 3
6 und 5 7 gegen die kasachische
spitzenspielerin je länger die band
china auch ihr zweites einzel und konnte
nicht für die wende sorgen nach drei
niederlagen lag das dtb-team
aussichtslos zurück
schade eigentlich
danke schön trotzdem sehr gerne noch
einen ausflugstipp für alle denen die
ostereiersuche zu langweilig ist das
fränkische klein hawaii für alle surfer
die neue fuchsloch welle in nürnberg
heute und morgen schwingen sich die
profis aufs brett bei den
meisterschaften im web surfen und
das wetter bleibt auch am ostersonntag
sehr angenehm mild mit viel sonne
details hat gleich katjana viertel vor
elf meldet sich marietta slomka mit dem
heute-journal wir danken ihnen für ihr
interesse und wünschen ihnen allen noch
ein schönes osterwochenende guten abend
[Musik]
[Applaus]